the next question is for rather than
alter poor Italian with his children few
I would be interested who is at the
movie set the big boss who has got the
biggest trailer and Wow it wasn't mine I
think it's Matthews that would be
correct Antonette what are the biggest
trailer uh well I have a lot of stuff
you know so I just you know it it's
really nice it's really you know I got a
you know he has like five of them
what you gotta fit the thought I got off
at them thighs and quads somewhere you
know but he is like five five of them
yeah well Robert actually has a smallest
trailer he just has another for trailers
this beautiful Airstream trailer yeah
there's there's actually the state of
Georgia want to give it its own zip code
it's like a kiddie choo-choo train
and it just goes around in a circle and
what's about you know train I didn't get
one no but we're maybe you got a chair
you haven't really come back from
Germany I remember that the first day
the first scene I had with with Robert
after five minutes he asked me if I had
allergies I didn't understand the
question
and when I had lunch and was eating my
burrito in my humble little trailer
somebody knocked at my door and said and
he was sitting in the Gulf Kenny he said
like you're cordially invited to Robert
Downey's Village my burrito and then in
the far distance I saw that huge space
with yeah four or five Tyler's you know
Thank You long palm trees at a
three-course meal right did you get my
and I always quite said when he left
because I was at the invited price
that's everybody's goal every day is
that lunch to see who's gonna get
invited
and you get so jealous like the day he
was invited I see I'm gonna mail I'm
like I'm not a Briton Carter of dmg you
probably introduced me to quinoa I was
like what is this beautiful grain Mali a
lot of marbles I'm putting in my mouth
like that's key now where do I buy they
had a good one I I wanted to have
Sebastian over sooner but he sent me
this video of him she's ripping out my
SEP girls with a decapitated iron man
just all of that thing and I was like
this guy's method that's now it's find
out what his allergies are
you